How one can know whether his iman is
strong or
weak and what step should be taken in
improving my
iman. And if one who listens about the
punishment of hellfire and not feeling
afraid of it but worries about other
things, what is the strength of his man?
The question posed by and he's asking
that how will a person come to know
whether his iman is strong or weak and
what steps should be taken to improve
the
iman and the last part is that if a
person hears and knows about the
punishment of hellfire and yet is not
worried about that and worried about the
worldly things then what is his status
regarding the first part of the question
that how does one come to
that is iman is strong. A person mean he
keeps on following the teachings of
Quran and say hadith. The more he
follows he realizes that iman is
strong. For example, when he goes out a
Muslim man knows that she should wear
the hijab. The outside world may not be
doing hijab. She'll do hijab. You know
that the iman is strong. We know that
people do wrong things. They cheat.
You're not cheating. People tell lies.
You don't lie. You're
honest and the more you follow the Quran
and say Hadith, you come to know iman
strong. How do you increase your iman?
One of the best way to increase your
iman is to read the translation of the
Quran. Read the translation of the
hadith of the beloved prophet wasallam.
Read the s of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Read the s of the of
the
sahabas. When you look at the
lifestyle, you are empowered.
you realize that how strong they were in
IM and how weak we are in IM. So if you
read the stories of the Sahabas, your
iman increases. I'd like to give you one
incident that once there are the person
who comes and there is a prophet that
the neighbor that is there is not
allowing you to build the boundary wall
of the house because the tree is in
between. So the prophet tells the
neighbor that if you give that one tree
and allow him to build his boundary wall
I will give you a tree in Jenna and he
refuses he doesn't agree. So when one of
the Sahabah Abu Dhab heard about this he
goes and asked the prophet that if I get
that tree and see it give it to him will
I get a tree in Jenna? The prophet said,
"Yes, why not?" So he goes and tells
that neighbor that do you know who I am?
He says no. He says I am Abu Dhan who
owns the biggest and the most precious
garden of dates in Medina. So it is of
course who doesn't know you then he says
that will you give me this tree which is
coming in between your neighbor boundary
wall and for that in exchange of that
tree I will give you my complete garden
of
dates which is the best in Madina. The
man says, "Are you crazy? Oh my tree,
you give me the full garden which is the
best in my says, yes." And the person
agrees. Abu
Dha comes back home and tells his wife
that today I have done a great deed, an
excellent deed. The wife asks, "What did
you do?" So he narrates the story about
the tree and he tells his wife that I
bought that tree that we gave us a tree
in Jenna in exchange for the full garden
that we have in Madina. So the wife says
ah what excellent be in today's world if
suppose you have such a big garden and
you want to buy the tree today's wife
will tell you you're a fool why did you
use the full garden you would have given
25% of the garden or you should have
given 50% of the garden and surely that
man would have even if you give 25% of
the garden you have the wrong tree but
look at the im the wife says ah what
that means
Both of them the husband and wife they
didn't want even an out of doubt that
the person refused because they wanted
Jenna and the hadith tells us that for
the rest of the life they lived a poor
life but they lived a very happy life
because they know that the prophet had
promised them paradise. So if we hear
the stories of the Sabbath, how they
live, how they sacrifice, how they
helped each other, the iman increases
and it gives us a feeling that what we
doing
nothing and we know that at the time of
jihad when the prophet told the Sabbath
that what do you want to contribute and
may Allah be pleased with him comes and
he gives the large wealth to the prophet
and the prophet asks him that what have
you left home. So he says I have left
half my wealth at home and half I'm
giving charity for
jihad after that later on Abu Bakr may
Allah be pleased with him. He comes and
he
gives his wealth to the prophet and the
prophet asks him what have you left
home? So he said I have given all my
wealth and I have left Allah and his
rasool at home to take care of us.
Imagine what iman imagine giving is
complete wealth in the way of Allah
subhanaa tala when we hear these stories
it increases our iman it makes us feel
so small that we can't even contribute
to the cause of Allah subhanaa tala we
can't even this charity if you read the
lifestyle the sid of the sahabas of the
of the prophets we are now we wage so if
you read the story the iman increases if
you read the Quran the translation I
increases And you can close with Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. Your ibada increases,
your salah increases, your song
increases, your fasting, your charity,
your zakat, all these things. These are
signs. And when we realize that
increased, we have peace of mind. Well,
canned by peace of mind. We have peace
of mind that mashallah inshallah we are
following Allah and his rasool and
inshallah we will be raised in Jenna
with Allah and his rasool as the prophet
said that you'll be raised with the
people whom you love. So that time the
farmers were so happy. They said we may
not be good indeed. We may they were the
best. After the
ambias the people who are the most
blessed and the closest to Allah subhana
are the among the number one among
the mayah number one.
Then if you hear these
stories and read the lifestyle of the
prophet and the sabas you realize that
we are living in air condition. We have
all the facility and yet we yet we don't
follow the sunnah yet we don't follow
the thing that we're supposed to do. And
if you read how did the Ansar the people
of Medina the Sabbas of Madina helped
the Sabas the muaj who migrated from
Makkah to Madina and the stories it's
phenomenal. So the more you read the s
of the prophet of the sabas your iman
will increase your practice will
increase and inshallah your peace of
mind will increase and you're more
secured that Allah will give you the
best in this world as well as